Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zurück in der Liga Tour zu Europa. Wir wollen heute blicken auf die Eredivisi. Wir wollen schauen nach Spanien und nach Italien. Und das tun wir mit Daniel Zander, Fabian Pakulat und Christian Bernhardt jetzt hier im Rasenfunk. Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Linien.
Hallo und herzlich Willkommen liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Schön, dass ihr wieder eingeschaltet habt und schön, dass ich unsere bekannte Runde hier zurück habe. Ich sag einfach mal hallo in die Runde an euch drei. Ihr könnt kollektiv antworten oder auch gar nicht. Entscheidet euch jetzt.
Das neue Bologna. Borussia Dortmund hat es gerade erst erfahren, auf den BVB kommen wir gleich nochmal. Weiteres Vorschreitwing. Jetzt aber nochmal eine Speed-Runde. Wobei Fabian, bei deinem Thema wird es schwierig da durchzusprinten. Ich hab's vorhin schonmal angesprochen. Wir sprechen über Dani Olmo, der kurz mal nicht registriert werden durfte und für den dann eine Ausnahmeregel gefunden wurde, damit er jetzt doch spielen darf.
Eine Ausnahmeregel der spanischen Regierung eigentlich, muss man sagen, vom spanischen Sportrat. Also da, Fußball ist Wahnsinn und in Spanien ist es auch sehr politisch. Also ganz kurz zum Einordner. Dani Olmo wurde im Sommer von Red Bull Leipzig geholt und war dann ganz lange nicht spielberechtigt, bis sich Gott sei Dank in Anführungszeichen Christensen verletzt hat. Diese Verletzung hat man ausgenutzt, um Dani Olmo einschreiben zu können. Sonst hätte es finanziell nicht gereicht in Spanien. Vielleicht nochmal ganz kurz zur Info. Gibt es den Salary Cap? Also das heißt, du darfst nicht mehr ausgeben, als du einnimmst. Und dementsprechend hast du ein fixes Gehaltsbudget. Da müssen deine Lizenzspieler reinpassen plus deine ganzen Vereinsangestellten. Und die hat Basa traditionell, würde ich schon fast sagen, überstrapaziert. Deswegen war die Geschichte mit Dani Olmo schwierig. Aber sie haben es dann geschafft durch die Verletzung von Christensen. Und jetzt im Winter, als Christensen wieder fit wurde, wollten sie dasselbe machen über die Verletzung von Ter Stegen, der ja bis Ende der Saison nicht mehr spielen wird. Aber das hat nicht so ganz geklappt. Und dann musste natürlich Basa nochmal nachlegen irgendwie. Und dann haben sie argumentiert mit einem neuen Nike Deal, den sie im Sommer glaube ich schon abgeschlossen haben, hat die Liga dann zurückgewiesen. Und dann haben sie es dann trotzdem irgendwie noch geschafft oder beziehungsweise an VIP Plätze verkauft im neuen Stadion, an einen arabischen Investmentfonds und haben da anscheinend nochmal 100 Millionen eingenommen. Trotzdem hat die Liga das noch abgelehnt und hat das irgendwie glaube ich auch damit argumentiert, dass das jetzt nicht in die aktuelle Saison mehr reinpasst und so weiter und so fort. Dann ist Laporta, der Präsident von Basa, nochmal vor den Spanischen Sportrat oder den Spanischen Sportgerichtshof gegangen und die haben ihm dann Recht gegeben und dementsprechend haben sie dann die Spielberechtigung bekommen für die Supercopa. Also es ging nicht nur um Dani Olmo, sondern auch um Pau Victor, das ist ein Spieler, der letztes Jahr in der zweiten Mannschaft noch gespielt hat. Es ist aber jetzt noch nicht so hundertprozentig klar, Max, ob sie wirklich in der Liga spielen dürfen, denn Liga-Chef Javier Tebas ist nach wie vor dafür, dass sie nicht die Ausnahmeregel bekommen, die der spanische Stadien eigentlich eingeräumt hat. Also das Ding ist noch nicht so hundertprozentig durch. Sie prüfen also in der Liga immer noch alles, was geht, um diese Spieler nicht einschreiben zu lassen. Und da geht es gar nicht darum, dass man, glaube ich, Barca ans Bein pinkeln möchte, wenn ich das so sagen darf, sondern es geht einfach um einen Gerechtigkeitssinn. Man hat in Spanien diese Vorgaben, die sind sehr hart, die sind aber auch gerecht und die sind eigentlich auch, glaube ich, in Europa relativ einmalig und eigentlich schon ein positives Beispiel oder ein Vorzeigmodell, wie ich finde. Andere Teams mussten darunter leiden, unter anderem mein Club, der FC Malaga. Ich darf das ganz kurz nur reiß das ganz kurz ab. Vor drei Saisons in der Covid-Saison haben wir dieses Budget überschritten und haben eine Sperre aufgesetzt bekommen, die da hieß, wir dürfen nur 18 Profi-Spiele haben und dürfen das über eineinhalb Saisons auch nur machen. Und müssen uns halt dadurch ja quasi wieder refinanzieren, sozusagen. Und das war eine ziemlich harte Strafe. Malaga ist unter anderem dort dann eben auch abgestiegen, hat es aber dann trotzdem geschafft, ja einigermaßen mit diesen 18 Lizenzspielern dann irgendwie über die Bühne zu kommen. Aber es war natürlich ein krasser finanzieller Cut. Las Palmas hat sich beschwert, denen wurde auch damals eine ziemlich harte Strafe aufgerückt. Und auch Atletico Madrid hat sich beschwert. Andere Vereine haben sich beschwert und gesagt, es kann nicht sein, dass wir diese Regeln einhalten und Barca immer wieder eine neue Stellschraube findet und einen neuen Hebel findet, um das irgendwie hinzubekommen. Aber es ist halt der FC Barcelona und es ist halt ein Politikum in Spanien. Und man möchte seine großen Lieblingsvereine nicht in einen schlechten Schatten international stellen. Und dann, glaube ich, ist man so ein bisschen zu dem Schluss gekommen, ihnen diese Spielberechtigung zu geben. Ob die Liga jetzt wirklich nochmal was dagegen machen kann, also quasi ob die Liga über den Start da nochmal rüber hinweg entscheiden kann. Ich weiß, ich mag es, ich mag nicht da in die Zukunft blicken. Es ist wirklich in Spanien oft sehr diffus. Fakt ist auf jeden Fall, kein anderer Verein, außer vielleicht noch Real Madrid, hätte irgendeine Chance gehabt, dort was zu machen. Und es ist eigentlich schade, dass es jetzt so passiert ist. Mir tut es natürlich auch für die Spieler leid und für den Verein und für Flick und so weiter. Es ist sportlich natürlich eine wirklich bescheidene Situation, aber entweder gelten Regeln für alle oder sie tun es eben nicht. Und dementsprechend hätte man dort schon ein Exempel jetzt mal statuieren müssen, auch mal gegen die Großen. Aber es scheint eben wieder nicht der Fall zu sein und dass ja Barca sich wieder irgendwie drum herum mogeln kann.
Da wird es ja noch Berichterstattung zu geben. Da bin ich ganz sicher.
Ich geh davon aus.
Was magst du uns noch aus den Niederlanden erzählen?
Ich möchte noch einen Fokus legen auf den Abschließkampf in der Riedivisie, denn der wird langsam wieder richtig spannend. Also wir haben mit Almere und Walwag zwei Tabellen letzter, 17 und 18. Die dürfen es vermutlich nicht so einfach haben. Die haben zehn, elf Punkte. Aber dann haben wir mit Sparta auf dem Relikationsplatz jemanden mit 17 Punkten und Groningen und Almelo mit 20 und 21 Punkten. Und gerade dieser Kampf um 16, der könnte in den nächsten Spieltagen noch mal sehr groß auflammen. Denn Sparta hat das geschafft, nach 14 sieglosen Spielen mal wieder zu gewinnen jetzt. Und zwar sogar gegen Alkmaar, also gegen den Top Team der Liga. Und das Erstaunliche bei Sparta ist, dass sie wirklich immer, also wirklich fast immer, an sehr knappen Ergebnissen scheitern. Die haben von den 20 Spielen, die sie gespielt haben, nur vier Spiele mit mehr als einem Tor Unterschied verloren. Es waren also immer irgendwelche Unentschieden oder 1-0, 2-1, 3-2. Es war also immer knapp, die hatten nur gegen Gültrecht, haben sie immer 4-1 verloren. Das war die einzig große Klatsche, Anführungszeichen, die sie erleiden mussten. Und es waren immer so Nuancen, es war immer ein bisschen Spielluck dabei oder Pfech in dem Sinne für Sparta. Und jetzt scheinen sie so ein bisschen sich auch geschläggert zu haben. Vor dem 2-1 gegen ALKMA haben sie auch schon zwei Punkte entschieden geholt. Also haben auch wieder mal in Serie gepunktet und haben jetzt kommende Woche das direkte Duell gegen Kroningen. Also da könnten sie bis auf einen Punkt ran an Kroningen, an die nicht Aftis glätzt und könnten, sollte Almelo verlieren, auch Almelo überholen. Und für Kroningen war es auch sehr bitter, denn die hatten gestern Abend um 20 Uhr hatten die ein Nachruhspiel, nämlich gegen Almelo, also in direkten Konkurrenten auch wieder. Und in den Nielanden ist es relativ üblich, dass wenn Spiele abgebrochen werden, die Uhr angehalten wird, und es dann einfach ein paar Wochen später, man sich auf einen neuen Termin einigt und dann ab dieser Uhrzeit angehaltenen Uhr weiterspielt. Und Kroningen gegen Almelo war Ende Dezember abgebrochen worden, ich glaube in der 79. Minute aufgrund von Vandalismus und von Ausschreitungen in den Fan-Blocken. Dann ist dann auch ganz, ganz tragisch ein Kroningen-Fan aus vier, fünf Metern in den Innenraum gestürzt, der aber zum Glück im Krankenhaus dann auch behandelt wurde, und dem es wohl gut geht. Und dann hat man entschieden, das Spiel abzubrechen. Und das wurde jetzt eben gestern ausgetragen bei Stand von Minute 78 und 45 Sekunden. Gab es dann noch immer schöne, schöne Bilder, wo sich dann Aymilo-Fans Schaße gekauft haben, 20 Minuten alles geben für Heracles und sich damit abgelichtet haben. Und es blieb aber bei dem 1 zu 1, das war der Stand, bei dem es abgebrochen wurde und vorgesetzt wurde. Das heißt, reicht eigentlich nicht für beide Vereine. Ein Punkt ist dann zu wenig in dem Duell für 14 gegen 15. Und deswegen ist Sparta so ein bisschen in den letzten Tagen und Wochen der lachende 3., der jetzt eben regelmäßiger punktet, der diese knappen Spiele auch mal wieder für sich entscheidet nach 14 sichtlosen Spielen und der jetzt wirklich gegen Kroningen dann dann noch mal einen Big Step machen kann. Hat aber auch gestern nach der guten Nachricht des 1-2-1, aber auch die nächste negative Nachricht erhalten, weil Verscharen, ein wichtiger Spieler von Sparta, ist wechselt und zur 20. Endstrecke gegangen ist. Also müssen sie auch quasi gleich wieder einen Abgang verkraften. Aber ist zumindest wieder spannend im Abschließkampf. Und das kann man auch noch sagen, im Meisterschaftskampf ist es auch wieder ein bisschen spannend, weil sich eben Ajax ganz, ganz heimklammheimlich nach oben gemogelt hat. Es ist jetzt vier Punkte nur noch hinter Eindhoven, hinter PSV, hat auch noch ein Spiel weniger, könnte also auf einen Punkt rankommen, wenn sie zum Beispiel den Klassiker gewinnen gegen Feyenoord jetzt am Wochenende. Also auch spannend. Und fragt mich nicht, wie genau Ajax da aufgekommen ist. Ich hab es selbst nicht ganz so verstanden. Es ist Licht und Schatten. Wenn man sich an die Euroleague-Konferenz erinnert oder an die Euroball League, haben sie gegen Riga verloren. Das war, glaube ich, der erste Sieg. Football, Skoda, Riga überhaupt international. Ausgerechnet natürlich gegen Ajax. Und es ist so ein bisschen bei Ajax das Ding, dass sie sich sehr schwer tun mit dem Ball, wenn der Gegner einfach sich hinten reinstellt, kompakt und dicht ist und von Ajax verlangt, mal aktiv das Spiel zu machen. Dann fällt es Ajax auch mit den vielen jungen Talenten, die sie noch haben, auch wenn die meist sagtens wirklich herausstechen, so ein Fidget-Sim zum Beispiel. Aber dann fällt es Ajax doch schwer und schwierig, da das Spiel auch mal konsequenter zu machen und kreativer zu sein. Es sieht dann wieder anders aus, wenn sie einen Gegner auf Augenhöhe haben, der auch versucht mitzuspielen. Sie hier PSV, da haben sie ja auch gewonnen in der Liga zum Beispiel. Und das ist so ein Punkt, an dem Ajax noch arbeiten muss.
Also Spannung an beiden Enden der Tabelle mit unmittelbarem Ausblick nach vorne. Da haben wir auch schon ein bisschen so Matches to Watch jetzt mit dabei gehabt, sowohl eben bei Sparta als auch jetzt bei Ajax und im Ferien-Nordblock ja sowieso. Christian, was hast du denn noch aus der Serie A?
Ja, ich hab noch eine kleine nette Geschichte. Ich hab noch ein Player to Watch vielleicht, den die wenigsten auf dem Zettel haben. Wir gehen nach Venedig. Also wir sind auch im Abstiegskampf in Italien und zwar spielt da ein gewisser Philipp Stankovic. Und ja Stankovic, wenn jetzt bei ein paar da ein Lichtlein angeht beim Name. Das ist der Sohn von Dejan Stankovic von der Inter-Legende. Trippelsieger, ja 2010 mit Inter. Aber anders als sein Papa, der ja ein Mittelfeldstrategie-Arbeiter war, ist Stankovic Torhüter. Und zwar ein richtig guter. Also er kommt auch aus der Jugend von Inter, hat da alle, mehr oder weniger alle Jugendklassen durchlaufen, ist dann vergangenes Sondern Sampdoria ausgeliehen worden, in die zweite Liga hat da schon viel gespielt und ist jetzt eben im Sommer an Venezia ausgeliehen worden und ist jetzt wirklich, ist mittlerweile statistisch einer der stärksten Torhüter der Liga und hat einen riesen Impact auf diese Mannschaft. Venedik hat von den letzten acht Spielen nur zwei verloren, haben leider auch viele von unentschieden gespielt, also sind trotzdem, ja stehen in der Tabelle als Vorletzter nicht wahnsinnig gut da, aber Stankovic hat ihnen in jedem Spiel eben die Chance gegeben was mitzunehmen. Also wie gesagt, dass die von den letzten acht Spielen nur zwei verloren haben, lag wirklich in vielen Punkten an Stankovic überragend auf der Linie, wirklich ganz ganz großartige Reflexe. 23 Jahre jung, also für einen Torhüter noch sehr jung. Und es ist mittlerweile jetzt wirklich so, dass bei Inter, weil da geht es jetzt mittelfristig dann schon auch um die Nachfolge von Jan Sommer, also im Moment ist ja mit Sommer logisch alles noch gut, gar keine Frage, mehr als gut sogar, aber logischerweise ist Sommer halt auch in einem gewissen Alter. Und jetzt gibt es schon bei Inter einige, die sagen, oh mein Gott, haben wir da womöglich im Sommer nicht vielleicht ein bisschen was falsch gemacht, denn Stankovic ist zwar in Venedig ausgeliehen, aber die haben eine Kaufoption und die Kaufoption liegt nur bei zwei Millionen Euro. Und eigentlich geht im Prinzip jeder davon aus, dass Venedig das zieht quasi, weil der Markt wirklich schon extrem gestiegen ist. Inter hat zwar 50 Prozent weiterverkauft, Rechte quasi, also wenn er dann weiterverkauft worden würde, dann würden sie stark daran beteiligt werden, aber man darf auch nicht ausschließen, also wie gesagt, trotzdem gibt es ja gute Beziehungen zwischen Inter und Venedig, da sind immer wieder auch andere junge Spieler dahin gewechselt. Also lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, ich würde nicht ausschließen, dass Inter auch probieren wird Stankovic mittelfristig zurückzuholen und man muss ihm wirklich zutrauen, ich glaube, der hat das Potenzial wirklich mittelfristig die Eins bei Inter zu werden. Also es ist wirklich seit Woche, Woche für Woche wirklich herausragend. Klar, du kannst bei einer kleinen Mannschaft auch mehr glänzen, ist schon klar, weil er mehr aufs Tor kriegt, aber es ist wirklich, er gibt der Mannschaft Ruhe, ist wirklich richtig stark, statistisch wie gesagt einer der besten der Liga und dementsprechend merkt ihr euch den Namen, vielleicht ist schon bald wieder Stankovic bei Inter, nur diesmal auf einer anderen Position. Und der allerletzte witzige Satz dazu, in Interkreisen gibt es so ein paar Nostalgiker, die sagen bitte, bitte, bitte in ein paar Jahren, wir wollen nicht nur Stankovic im Tor, sondern wir wollen auch Klinsmann im Tor, denn wie ich sich vielleicht ein paar erinnern, der Sohn von Jürgen Klinsmann ist ja auch Torhüter und der spielt in der Serie B, also in der zweiten Liga, macht auch einen guten Job und deswegen ja in Inter-Fan-Kreisen, komm wir wollen dann irgendwann Stankovic im Tor. Also der zweite Teil ist jetzt eher lustig, aber mit Stankovic, das ist mehr als nur ein cooler Spruch. Also wirklich ein sehr, sehr aufstrebender, vielversprechender, starker Torhüter.
Spannend, sehr gut. So und jetzt hab ich noch ein Thema mitgebracht. Ihr müsst jetzt entscheiden, wie viel Zeit ihr noch habt. Wir sind ja eigentlich schon nahe dem Ende. Aber weil mir das einfiel, wir haben ja in der Unsung Hero Kategorie hier so oft Trainer mit dabei, interessante Trainer-Talente. Und jetzt haben wir ja mit dem BVB einen Verein, der einen neuen Trainer braucht und dem einen Impuls von außen sehr, sehr gut täte. Und nach allem, was man bisher hört, sind aber nur die üblichen Verdächtigen, plus noch Alf Rangnick in der Verlosung bei BVB. Ist mir jetzt völlig egal, was davon realistisch ist. Aber ich hätte jetzt an euch die Frage und bin gespannt, wie ihr antwortet, welche Trainer-Talente, bei denen es halbwegs realistisch wäre, dass sie auch zum BVB kämen, also braucht jetzt nicht Hansi Flick sagen, gäbe es denn in euren Ligen, die vielleicht sogar verfügbar wären oder die gerade bei einem Verein wären, wo man sagen würde, ey, der Schritt nach Dortmund könnte sich auch lohnen. Fabian, hast du da einen Namen für mich?
Den ich vorher genannt hab von Rayo Vallecano, der ist mir noch zu jung, mit 37, das ist der Schritt, Dortmund kommt natürlich zu früh. Aber es gibt natürlich schon spannende Trainer in Spanien, ob das jetzt Ernesto Valverde von Bilbao ist oder zum Beispiel Marcelino von Villareal. Aber ich trau denen nicht den Schritt zu Dortmund zu. Auch der Schritt damals von Marcelino zu Olympique Marseille ist ja auch gescheitert. Das sind Spieler, die funktionieren, glaube ich, gut in Spanien, aber nicht außerhalb. Es gibt aber einen spanischen Trainer, den ich extrem interessant finde und der mit Sicherheit dorthin passen würde. Das ist Andoni Iraola, Trainer vom Bournemouth, der im Moment, ja, weiß ich nicht, so in der WM vierter, fünfter oder so. Er macht einen unheimlich riesigen Job. Schon letztes Jahr, wie ich finde, der hat vorher auch Rayo als erste Trainerstation gehabt. Rayo war ja Kano, das ist ein Sprungbrett für interessante Trainer in Spanien, war jahrelang Rechtsverteidiger bei Athletic Bilbao, ist nie gewechselt, war immer beim selben Club und ist unwahrscheinlicher Fußball, was heißt Lehrer, Philosoph auch. Und was der mit Bournemouth macht, ist unglaublich. Der würde Dortmund aber mal richtig gut zu Gesicht stehen. Aber ich habe fast eher bei ihm das Gefühl, dass es nächste Session noch eine Stufe vielleicht sogar weiter nach oben geht als bis zum BVB.
Könnte schon zu groß sein für den BVB, meinst du. Aber klar Bournemouth gerade Tabellen siebte, über die hätten wir vielleicht geredet, wenn wir Pramilic heute mit dabei gehabt hätten. Also das ist absolut fantastisch.
Also der ist wirklich herausragend. Ich habe jetzt viel auch aus Italien von Kollegen mitbekommen. Vielleicht zur Einnung ist ein Bielsa Schüler. Also ganz, ganz viele Grundprinzipien vom Bielsa. Also was der mit denen da oben macht, das ist ganz großes Kino. Also ich glaube auch, dass der vielleicht schon in anderen Sphären auch schon, nicht nur vielleicht auch schon gehandelt wird. Also ich glaube, das wäre ein Riesenstil für Dortmund, wenn ihnen das gelingen würde.
Ja, Tottenham braucht ja vielleicht bald jemanden. Ja, das könnte das Näherliegende sein. Ja, Christian, wenn du jetzt grad eh schon mit dabei warst, also gerade bei Italien hatten wir das ja in den letzten Jahren so oft, dass wir über interessante Trainer gesprochen haben. Du hast ja vorher auch schon wieder eine ganze Reihe von Trainern genannt. Wen gäbe es denn da, wo du sagen würdest, können ja auch mehrere sein, die könnten passen?
Also ich fange erstmal mit denen an, die verfügbar waren, wären, jetzt schon quasi. Das sag ich einfach mal Roberto Mancini und Daniele De Rossi. Meine Meinung zu De Rossi kennt er ja. Also ich finde, der würde jeden gut tun und ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob De Rossi und Dortmund, ob da irgendwie Berührungspunkte sind. Was ich aber bei De Rossi glaube, ist, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit gar nicht so klein ist, dass der erstmal ins Ausland geht. Also bei dem könnte ich mir gut vorstellen. Also ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass der jetzt schon im Sommer, dieses Jahr nimmt man sich jetzt einfach noch nach dieser ganzen Roma-Nummer glaube ich, nimmt man sich bewusst raus. Aber im Sommer ist er sicher wieder ein Kandidat für, da werden auch im Hintergrund schon Gespräche laufen. Und ich kann mir bei dem vorstellen, dass der wirklich auch vielleicht erstmal einen Schritt raus als Italien machen möchte, um dann wieder zurückzukommen jetzt mit dieser ganzen emotionalen Roma-Nummer. Aber ein Trainer, der ist so ähnlich wie bei Fabian. Und ich hatte halt auch das Zufall, dass wir ihn vorhin hatten, aber ich finde von der Art und Weise, wäre Vincenzo Italiano wirklich einer, der sehr gut zur Bundesliga auch passen würde. Es ist wirklich dieses Gegenpressing, dieses wirklich intensive Spiel, das der Pater Fiorentina schon aufgezogen hat, das er jetzt mit Bologna weiter durchzieht. Also von der Art und Weise muss ich sagen, wäre das wirklich was, glaube ich, was passen könnte. Ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass Italiano, das ist schon auch einer, der gerne was aufbaut. Deswegen glaube ich kaum, dass du den jetzt auch im Sommer aus Bologna wegkriegst. Weiß ich nicht, ob der gleich schon geht. Vor allen Dingen spielt er womöglich nächstes Jahr auch wieder europäisch mit Bologna. Aber nur rein vom Typ her, weil du ja meintest, Max eben was könnte passen, ist das wirklich was, glaube ich, was sehr gut zur Bundesliga passen könnte. Weil es Grundprinzipien von dem, starke Bezugspunkte zur Bundesliga gibt. Eine Sache, die kann man jetzt ja dann noch einbauen, die hatte ich vorhin noch nicht erwähnt. Es ist nicht nur Pressing und Gegenpressing, sondern Bologna hat auch den dritthöchsten Ballbesitz in der Liga. Also die haben knapp nach Inter und Juve. Also das ist auch eine dominante Mannschaft. Das ist nur, wenn der Gegner den Ball hat, dann beißen sie zu und schnappen rein. Aber die können durchaus was mit dem Ball auch anfangen. Es ist nicht nur eine reine Truppe, die nur auf wilde Ballgewinne geht, sondern das ist eine sehr gut strukturierte Mannschaft, die aber wirklich als Riesenplus und in Italien ragt es vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr raus als in der Bundesliga. Wirklich dieses wahnsinnig intensive Pressing und Gegenpressing und anlaufen hat und dementsprechend. Also ich finde Italierner auch schon länger, glaube ich, hatten wir hier auch schon ein, zwei mal einen sehr spannenden Trainer. Also das wäre vielleicht einer vom Profil her.
Und der Rossi war in Dortmund, das könnte man sich auch sehr, sehr gut vorstellen, egal wie realistisch es ist. Eine kurze Beobachtung übrigens zum Pressing, ganz interessant. Die Bundesliga ist da gar nicht mehr so wie ihr ruft. Wenn man sich nämlich zum Beispiel die PBDA-Werte anguckt von den Top-Leagern, dann siehst du, in Deutschland nur ein Team mit einem Wert unter zehn. Und da hast du in La Liga irgendwie acht Teams.
Unter zehn, genau, gepayern, gell?
In der Serie A sechs Teams. Echt acht? Ich glaube schon, es waren sehr, sehr viele. Ich muss noch mal gerade nachgucken in irgendeiner der Ligen, wo ich geguckt habe.
Ich hab's vorhin auch, weil das hat mich jetzt...
Fünf waren's in der Premier League.
Nee, schau in Italien. Sorry, schau in Italien, ist das wirklich nur Bologna unter zehn. Es sind dann einige mit zehn, das stimmt. Mit zehn hast du dann Lazio, Inter, Juve, Atalanta, die sind alles so um zehn rum. Aber unter zehn hast du zum Beispiel wirklich nur Bologna. Das ist ja sogar unter acht.
Ich hab mich gerade in den Ligen geirrt, genau. Also auf jeden Fall, was ich nur damit sagen wollte, dieser Pressing-Liga-Aspekt, den es gibt, die Liga war das mit den vielen Teams, Entschuldigung, da waren es richtig viele, sieben Stück unter zehn. Aber das stimmt gerade gar nicht mehr so. Warum? Weil sehr viel Mittelfeld-Pressing, Union hat der Liga da ein bisschen was beigebracht, deswegen alle eher in so einem abwarten 5-3-2 oder 5-2-3 und mal situativ rausrücken. Und du hast halt mit Leverkusen und Stuttgart und in Teilen mit Bayern, je nachdem welcher Trainer gerade da war, hast du Teams, die dich halt brutal dafür bestrafen können, wer dir einfach zack, zack, zack durchspielen. Und das schafft inzwischen auch Mainz und Fünf, St. Pauli schafft das auch hin und wieder. Deswegen, entweder ist die Bundesliga da weiter als andere Ligen, ist das quasi schon die Reaktion auf das Pressing oder sie hängt zurück. Das muss ich zum Glück nicht beantworten. Daniel, ich habe mehrfach gelesen von BVB-Fans, wir brauchen jetzt unseren Louis van Gaal, jemanden, der wie damals beim FC Bayern reinkommt und einmal aufräumt und einmal sagt, hier guck mal, Fußball funktioniert übrigens so. Gibt es den neuen Louis van Gaal?
Nein, also das ist glaube ich gut so. Ich glaube, Louis van Gaal und BVB, als ich das Gerücht gesehen habe, war ich noch sehr froh.
Nicht ihn selbst, aber quasi diese Art Trainer quasi.
Auch diese Art Trainer würde ich beim BVB eigentlich ungern sehen wollen. Ich hatte an einen anderen Typen gedacht, der jetzt nicht knurrt, es ist kein Knurrhahn ist, sondern auch kein Talent mehr ist, der ist 66, sondern Ron Janz von FC Utrecht. Die hatte ich glaube ich hier auch schon mal vormistet in der älteren Folge, glaube ich. Und der ist einfach, der bringt unfassbar viel Erfahrung mit. Der war auch in den USA bei Cincinnati und hat aber auch in der Eredivisie eigentlich alles, was er angefasst hat, wurde auch irgendwie zu Gold. Also der hat Twente, die ja zwischenzeitlich abgestiegen waren, hat hier wieder zur Altersstärke hochgeführt. Da wurde mit den Fürther vor einigen Jahren und ist dann aus freien Stücken gegangen. Also da wurde er nicht rausgeschmissen, sondern er hat gesagt, okay, ich habe jetzt hier mehrere Jahre trainiert und gearbeitet. Wir haben viel erreicht und für mein Verständnis ist jetzt das, was ich erreichen konnte, erfüllt. Ich habe den Verein in einer guten Lage hinterlassen und es ist jetzt mal eine Zeit hier abzutreten, den Platz freizumachen für wen neu ist, um irgendwie eine neue Herausforderung zu suchen. Und die fand er in Utrecht und aktuell sind die auf Platz drei. Also macht er eigentlich genau da weiter, wo er bei Twente aufgehört hat, die jetzt auch echt, ich glaube auch, dass Utrecht am Ende der Saison Europäisch spielt, jetzt nicht zwingt Champions League, aber durchaus Europäisch spielen wird mit Conference oder Europa League. Und er hat so sein System, er hat so sein 4-2-3-1-System, was er macht, was ja in Dortmund auch vorstellbar ist. Und ich meine, da auch schon gespielt wurde eigentlich. Jetzt wird's gegen die Prämie auch. Und das passt also schon gut. Aber er hat einfach auch diese Erfahrung, er hat die Ruhe, er lässt auch viel pressen in dem System und er hat so ein bisschen, er ist auch sehr polyvalent quasi so ein bisschen. Also er hatte, er war mal bei Zwolle, es war in den 14, 2014, 2013, 14, da hat er wirklich die defensive Trickkiste ausgepackt und wirklich sehr kompakt hinten gestanden und wirklich sehr versucht, Flusskante dort zu kassieren, hat sich dann aber in den Jahren weiterentwickelt, auch gerade nach Cincinnati und bei Zwente und hat angefangen, wirklich ein Kombinationsspiel aufzuführen. Und ich glaube, diese Mischung würde Dortmund gut zu Gesicht stehen, dass sie eben diese Abstimmung, gerade diese Konterabsicherung, gerade so die defensive Abstimmung, die ja bei Dortmund durchaus nach Akiri ist, in dem letzten Spiel gewesen ist. Da könnte Ron Janss einer sein, der da wieder ein bisschen bessere Balance herstellt, ohne aber das offensive Gewalt zu vernachlässigen, was du ja mit dem Kader von Dortmund auch nicht kannst. Insofern ist das einer, wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, das könnte passen. Verfügbarkeit ist die andere Frage. Ich könnte mir aber gerade bei ihm auch vorstellen, dass er nach der Saison, wenn jetzt Dortmund eine Übergangslösung, gibt ja auch verschiedene Modelle, die im Gespräch sind beim FVB, dass jemand für die Halbserie jetzt noch kommt und im Sommer eine neue Lösung kommt, dann könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass er sagt, okay, ich hab bisher auch bei Utrecht erfolgreich gehabt, eine gute Zeit gehabt, ich hab die auf Platz drei, vier, wo auch immer abgeschlossen und bin dann noch bereit noch mal für einen Schritt ins Ausland. Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Die Frage ist, ob generell die Frage wird sein, ob Dortmund einen eher unbekannten Namen sich daran traut oder ob es dann auch vom Nachmittag die größere Lösung sein muss. Da fällt dann wer wie Erikton Haag zum Beispiel ins Auge, der ja auch angeblich schon im Stadion war und so. Aber ich persönlich würde mich freuen, wenn Ron Janz es wäre, auch wenn ich es nicht glaube.
Wenn ihr mehr zu Ron Janz wissen wollt, liebe Hörer, dann hört die Ligatur vom 31.10. des letzten Jahres. Da haben wir eben länger über Ulrich gesprochen. Da hast du uns das alles schon mal erzählt. Ja, mal gucken. Vielleicht bekommt er dortmit auch seinen neuen Bert von Marwijk. Da hat er ja durchaus schon seine Erfahrungen gemacht. Ja, danke euch nochmal, dass wir diesen kleinen Schlenker noch machen durften. Christoph, wolltest du gerade noch was sagen?
Max, ganz kurz noch, sorry. Ja, sorry, nur ganz kurz, weil ich extra nochmal, weil ich es jetzt eben auch so spannend fand, ich habe jetzt auch nochmal in die Daten ein bisschen reingeklickt. Also es ist, die Kombination bei Italiano ist wirklich eine Spezielle, weil er eben auch diesen hohen Ballbesitz hat. Also quasi, es gibt ja dann viele Teams, die haben diesen hohen PPDA-Wert, aber die sind dann schon teilweise, zum Beispiel Mainz habe ich mir jetzt noch kurz mal rausgeschaut, die haben halt einen Ballbesitz von 47 Prozent. Also da geht es dann schon auch über das Element quasi und Bologna finde ich verknüpft das ganz gut, weil es ist eben, deswegen wollte ich es nur noch mal sagen, das ist nicht nur eine reine Gegenpressing-Mannschaft, sondern es ist eine Mannschaft, die es schon liebt auch den Ball zu haben. Und noch mal, die sind bei 57 Prozent in der Serie A, nur Inter und Juve haben ein bisschen mehr. Die sind vor Milan, vor der Roma, vor Napoli, vor Atalanta. Also die Kombination da glaube ich ist schon ganz eine spannende, dass du das mit Ballbesitz aus einer guten Struktur heraus dann in Kombination mit Aggressiven und Intensiven.
Und irgendwie wär es doch nett, wenn Dortmund ins Bayern-Playbook greift und sich den Trainer des Teams ruht gegen, dass man eine habe Klatsche auf hat. Das ist ja auch ganz nett. Das ist Rheumakei mit anderen Mitteln und in anderer Konstellation. Ihr drei, ich danke euch sehr herzlich, das hat große Freude gemacht. Das nächste Mal, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, werden wir wahrscheinlich auch wieder andere Ligenkombinationen mit dabei haben. Es ging sich diesmal nicht so aus. Aber ihr kennt das ja aus der Ligatur. Hier wird ein bisschen durchrotiert, so wie es ja auch sein soll. Ich danke sehr, sehr herzlich Daniel, Fabian und Christian. Danke, dass ihr hier mit dabei wart und euch die Zeit genommen habt. Danke euch.
War wie immer schön.
Sehr gerne.
Sehr schön war es.
Und ich freue mich natürlich auch, dass Sendungen wie diese hier möglich sind, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Und zwar allein durch euch. Ihr wisst ja, der Rasenfunk ist paywall-werbe- und sponsor- und frei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Auf rasenfunk.de/supporterscluberfahrtihr, wie das geht. Oder einfach auf rasenfunk.de und auf den unterstützen Button klicken. Und in dieser Folge bedanke ich mich bei Wasserturm 68165, bei Bene, bei Alex T., bei Tom K aus M., bei Alex, bei Lydia, Wildpark, Panda und bei Enro. Sie alle sind Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter. Herzlichen Dank dafür. Und an dieser Stelle auch gerne der Hinweis, wenn ihr Feedback habt, dann könnt ihr uns dieses geben auf mitmachen.rasenfunk.de in unserem Forum und abonniert doch sehr gerne auch die anderen Feeds, die es gibt vom Rasenfunk. Also zur Bundesliga der Männer, zur Bundesliga der Frauen, zu Nationalteams. Da sprechen wir über alle Nationalteams, Spiele Deutschlands und über die großen Turniere und das Tribüngespräch. Da gibt es jetzt auch eine neue Folge zum Polizeikostenurteil. In diesem Sinne, bleibt gesund, bis bald, ciao!
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank!